today we're going to talk about how to
stop
flatulence now the average person
according to they
farts between 5 to 15 times a day with
no
odor
now you might be sitting down there
saying i fart more than that or i fart
less than that or i don't fart at all
but this is an average person so it's
kind of like saying the average person
consumes
145 pounds of sugar per year well
i consume
zero sugar in a year so some people
consume a tremendous amount
and some
a small amount but we're looking at the
average but an average person expels gas
at a frequency between 5 to 15 a day now
there's been times in your life that you
may have experienced this more depending
on what you eat for example if you're in
college and you eat this thing called
hormel chili for example
you may experience more flatulence i
know for me i had a problem in my late
20s when i was
trying to become a vegan for a few
months it didn't really work out but if
you have a problem now i'm going to show
you exactly what to do to resolve it now
since we're on the topic of farts i have
to bring up cow farts and burps okay
because if you do a search on flatulence
uh the first i don't know how many pages
we'll talk about how cows are farting
and burping
and releasing about 160 to 320 liters of
methane per day and that's basically
causing the global warming etc etc
but if you actually dig into
all the data and research you're going
to find some real interesting things
about that that counter
that theory and give you some of the
data that's missing and never included
when they're talking about this topic
and i'm going to put that research down
below but between 1990 and 2007
a global cattle and buffalo population
increased by a factor of 125
million
extra cows and buffalo on this planet
and during that period of time there was
zero increase
in methane but this data is always
omitted when they're talking about this
topic so again when you're trying to
evaluate information
you really need to have all the
information to come up with the right
conclusion there are many other things
that are much bigger in contributing to
more methane than cows all right so what
causes flatulence
well we have certain fiber that you eat
certain carbohydrates that you eat in
the form of sugar
starches okay that are then fermented so
microbes are acting on these fibers and
sugars
and they're
eating them that's their food and as a
byproduct hydrogen is released and then
methane is also released now this
process should occur
in your large intestine it should not
occur in the small intestine when it
does
you get what's called sibo small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth and that
can create a lot of gas and a lot of
problems and one of the causes for sibo
is a lack of stomach acid in fact one of
the big causes of gas in general
is a lack of stomach acid as we get
older we lose the acidity in our stomach
if we take antibiotics we start losing
the stomach acid if we take antacids we
lose the stomach acid there's a lot of
things that we're exposed to that can
contribute to less stomach acid
now if we don't have the right ph in our
stomach between like one and three which
is very very acidic
food gets undigested and uh if it's
undigested
everything below the stomach has a more
difficult time breaking that food down
and that creates all sorts of strain and
stress on the enzyme production from
your pancreas from the gallbladder
releasing bile
from the small intestine to do its work
and then you can start getting
fermentation
in the small intestine and again that's
called sibo and this is where a person
can starts consuming fiber okay even
from vegetables and they really just
blow up like a balloon and they're
they're confused because they're saying
well i'm eating this good healthy food
why do i feel so bad they can have very
severe bloating and pain and very severe
gas
simply because you have these bacteria
that are in the wrong place and we're
getting fermentation in the wrong place
so here's the solution to
lack of stomach acid
betaine hydrochloride
the chloride contributes and improves
the hydrochloric acid okay so this
breaks down and helps you build up your
stomach acid it works great
these come in tablets
you can
take a couple okay it might make a
slight difference but i always recommend
take a little bit more because sometimes
you might need six seven eight at a time
to create the effect that you want
especially in the beginning and over
time you'll need less and less and less
because your body will start just making
more to the point where you don't you
won't need
any any uh help building your stomach
acid and i also recommend a couple herbs
that are really good for digestion
ginger really really good
for not just helping you with gas but to
help release
bile to help release enzymes and also to
help with any type of spasms going on in
the small intestine or tightness so it
just allows you to relax more in that
area so you can digest
any type of mint is really good for
digestion and fennel
now what about apple cider vinegar is
that good well if you actually look up
some of the credible sites on google
it'll tell you there's no research that
says that drinking apple cider vinegar
will help you with digestion but my
opinion is i don't really care if
there's a study or not i know it works
i've done it myself
i've given it to my patients it works on
a lot of people
and who's going to spend the money on
the research on apple cider vinegar
unless you own an apple cider vinegar
company
no one's going to spend that money
instead most the money in researching
digestive problems is going to be funded
by
medication who can afford to spend money
on research on digestive problems
pharmaceutical companies not your
average joe that wants to do a study an
apple cider vinegar but there is some
research on acetic acid and slowing your
digestion down
so
the enzymes in your small intestine can
start acting on the food and contribute
to more complete digestion and so the
faster the food goes through your
digestive system
the less complete the digestion is going
to be i mean just think about if someone
has
diarrhea right food could go right
through you undigested but if there's
something that can slow down the
digestion like apple cider vinegar
and consuming enough fat at the meal the
rest of the digestive juices can act on
that food and really break it down to
the point where you don't get these
problems with gas and extra methane and
bloating and other related symptoms so
both betaine hydrochloride and apple
cider vinegar are really good
to reduce flatulence and hopefully get
rid of it completely all right now let's
talk about food intolerances like
lactose intolerance right this is not a
true allergy but you're just intolerant
because you don't have the enzymes to
break down this milk sugar so anything
dairy can create a lot of gas a lot of
people have a problem with this now you
can take enzymes for that
or just avoid dairy then you have gluten
a lot of people have an allergy to
gluten and some people don't but they
have an intolerance for gluten and that
can create a lot of gas bloating pain
arthritis etc so the good thing about
what i recommend is if you're on a
healthy keto you're not going to have to
worry about it because you're not going
to be consuming gluten or grains for
that matter but for any type of
intolerances you can always take more
enzymes you can also take probiotics to
help
fortify the microbes so they can make
more enzymes
i found a lot of people that have food
allergies if they take certain
probiotics they can actually reduce
their food allergies okay then we have
what's called gas producing
foods like fruit is a big one right
beans legumes starches like potato
rice
uh things like that grains
sugars
certain cruciferous vegetables like
brussels sprouts okay
broccoli
cabbage
then you have like onions and garlic
these are very gas producing for certain
people
other people can consume them without a
problem but if you are on the ketogenic
plan you're not going to be doing fruit
you're not going to do beans you're not
going to do starches you're not going to
do sugar so you're going to be in good
shape now if you have a problem with
cruciferous vegetables there are other
vegetables that will not produce gas
like lettuce tomato zucchini olives and
avocado okay so just eat more of these
right here i will say when i recommend
the healthy version of the ketogenic
diet i recommend that people consume a
lot more
greens and salads and vegetables however
for some people
they don't have the microbes to handle
that much fiber so you want to go slow
and you want to gradually go into it
but a good percentage of the people just
jump right in they have a really big
salad each day and there's no problem
but the benefit of the fiber to feed the
microbes as well as the potassium the
magnesium the vitamin c and all those
phytonutrients
can greatly help a person and take their
health to a whole new level all right
number four sugar alcohols
when someone starts the ketogenic diet
inevitably they're going to be
really into all these really cool
desserts you can now have and make
with these little keto cookies and they
have little bars and they're filled with
these keto friendly fiber like corn
fiber and other fibers like dextrin that
are considered keto friendly that create
a lot of gas for people
inulin might create a lot of gas and
it's in a lot of different keto friendly
products inulin is a type of fiber and
then you have the sugar alcohols like
erythritol
xylitol
mannitol which for a lot of people can
produce a lot of gas so you will quickly
find out if you can tolerate
these sugar alcohols once you start the
ketogenic plan i think a lot of people
when they start keto they go overboard
and just consume a lot of the stuff
i would just recommend testing the
waters do a little bit
i use
xylitol non-gmo
on a regular basis in my coffee i'll
just have one in my coffee each day i'm
good it creates no problem whatsoever
but i just wanted to bring up sugar
alcohols because that is definitely one
source of
flatulence number five
chewing gum especially if you have your
mouth open you can be swallowing a lot
of air eating with your mouth open okay
you can swallow a lot of air and that
could end up with some gas
so eat with your mouth closed and if
you're going to chew gum keep your mouth
closed captioning not
available on apple cider vinegar that
i've gotten over 14 million views you
have to check this out if you haven't
seen it before i put it right here
you